Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wir lesen wieder was. Was wollen wir lesen?
Wir lesen Peter Sloterdijk, ein Philosoph, der immer wieder für Provokationen
sorgt, der aber auch Debatten anstößt und der sich mit den ganz großen Fragen beschäftigt.
Und dieses Mal ist es so, dass Peter Sloterdijk eingeladen war,
in Paris seine Vorlesung zu halten über Europa.
Er musste also über Europa nachdenken und das Buch dazu ist jetzt erschienen
und es trägt den Titel Der Kontinent ohne Eigenschaften und der Untertitel lautet
Lesezeichen im Buch Europa.
Europa wird also wie ein Buch behandelt und Peter Sloterdijk gibt uns jetzt
Lesezeichen an die Hand oder ist es etwas anderes damit gemeint, wir werden sehen.
Also wir kennen ja von YouTube das Format des Reaction-Videos.
Und wenn wir hier ein Angebot bekommen, jemand blättert in den Büchern Europas,
schreibt dann darüber und wir lesen dann darüber, um wieder darüber zu reden.
Das ist doch eigentlich Salon im Quadrat.
Peter Sloterdijk ist ja ein begnadeter Schriftsteller, möchte ich auch sagen.
Also er ist ein Philosoph, aber er ist ein schriftstellerischer Philosoph.
Er kann mit Worten umgehen wie kaum ein anderer.
Er ist ein Formulierungskünstler und er hat Humor. Und das merkt man gleich,
wenn man beginnt, das Buch zu lesen.
Ich will nur mal die ersten beiden Sätze vorlesen.
Unter allen Vorwürfen, die gegen das seltsame politische Gebilde namens Europa
und seine Bewohner in jüngeren Tagen laut geworden sind, sie ergeben eine lange
Litanei, wollte man sie vollständig hören,
dürfte der mildeste jener sein, wonach es durch seine telefonische Unerreichbarkeit auffalle.
Man hat dem Altgedienten im November 2023 versprochen, verstorbenen Politologen
Henry Kissinger, einem vormaligen Außenminister der USA,
das Scherzwort zugeschrieben, er wisse nicht, welche Nummer er wählen könnte,
falls er Europa an die Leitung bekommen wollte.
Ist ja eigentlich einer der großen Vorzüge gewesen. Man hat immer gehört,
wir Industriellen und Händler Superreichen, sag ich mal, wussten immer,
wie das mit dem Lobbyismus funktioniert und dann hieß es plötzlich,
die Zuständigkeit liegt jetzt in Europa und wir wussten nicht mehr weiter.
Wir wissen heute auch, Brüssel ist durchseucht, aber vielleicht kann man ja
nochmal an die gute alte Erinnerung heran, in denen Europa ein bisschen funktionierte, wie auch immer.
Meine Idee war ja sowieso, Rom gesehen und gesagt, haltet doch alles an und baut wieder auf.
Das Kolosseum einfach wieder herrichten, jede einzelne Statue.
Wofür? Na, um da Veranstaltungen stattfinden zu lassen.
Diese Idee fruchtet irgendwie nicht so richtig, aber...
Und du willst die Musealisierung Europas vorantreiben.
Das ist ja übrigens eine Idee von einem Sloterdijk-Freund, Bason Brock,
der hat ein Buch mal geschrieben, das heißt Musealisiert euch und da schlägt er genau das vor.
Wir führen dann den Touristen vor, was war das für eine Idee mit Europa und
was sind die Menschenrechte, aber nur noch als Freizeitpark dann genossen.
Genau. Venedig war immer nur ein Freizeitpark. Es ging immer nur um die Fassade.
Damals wie heute. Warum sollte man es nicht genauso wieder aufbauen?
Also ich habe da klare Präferenzen und ich finde auch, dieser Kampf um Schlüsseltechnologien,
ich werde ihm langsam müde.
Klot ist für mich das Ende der Technik. Ich brauche kein besseres Klot.
Naja, warten wir ab. Es kommt wahrscheinlich nicht aus Europa,
aber es wird da doch schon,
naja, also ich hoffe ja schon, dass es noch ein bisschen weiter geht,
außer ein kleines Fenster, in das ich Fragen reinschreiben kann oder einen Text
hochladen kann und bitten kann, mir das zusammenzufassen oder ein bisschen weiter zu spinnen.
Wolfgang, der moderne Mensch liegt mit Kopfhörern auf dem Sofa und redet mit
der KI. Der schreibt nicht.
Wegen mir das aber, ich sehe jetzt eher Fortschritte vielleicht bei der Robotik kommen.
Also nicht, dass ich jetzt glaube, dass die Pflegeroboter uns retten werden,
aber ich denke, dass dort, wenn es dann irgendwann kostengünstig produziert
werden kann, tatsächlich immense Fortschritte noch kommen können.
Also für mich ist jetzt noch nicht aller Tage Abend, aber es ist vielleicht
auch Ausdruck von Europa, dass du als Europäer eigentlich dir gar nicht so viel
erwartest, sondern du sagst, mir reicht das jetzt schon mal.
Also es ist ja eine Genügsamkeit.
Ja, du bist ein Mann der Zukunft, ich der Vergangenheit. Es sieht zwar nicht
so aus, wenn man uns beide sieht, aber die Rollen sind vertauscht.
Ja,
möglicherweise.
Ja, Peter Sloterdijk ist ja jemand, der der Zukunft sehr zugewandt ist,
der auch dann provoziert mit zum Beispiel einem Text wie Regeln für den Menschenpark.
Aber das war gar kein darwinistisch-sozial-darwinistischer Text in meinen Augen.
Habermas hat den ja damals sehr angegriffen oder angreifen lassen von anderen dann.
Ich finde sehr interessant, dass Sloterdijk sich immer wagt,
eigentlich in einer nizianischen Tradition weiterzudenken, auch dahin zu gehen,
wo es dann tatsächlich wehtut, wo man aus einem liberal-demokratischen Konsens plötzlich ausschert.
Also bei Peter Sloterdijk wird quasi Free Speech großgeschrieben,
könnte man sagen und manche werden nun einwenden,
aber Sloterdijk, das ist doch eher so ein rechter oder libertärer Philosoph
und ja, das alles, aber man kann ihn auch nicht ganz greifen.
Dann Slavoj Shizek, der ja auch mit Sloterdijk befreundet ist,
hat Sloterdijk ja mal gesagt, dass wenn er irgendwann an die Macht kommt,
also Shizek mit seinen Freunden und die Gulags wieder eingerichtet werden,
dann hat er Sloterdijk eine gute Stellung,
also er muss natürlich auch ins Gulag, aber er bekommt dann eine gute Stellung, nämlich als Koch.
Das heißt also, ganz so arg wird er ihn nicht behandeln. In gewisser Weise kann
man Sloterdijk auch als linker Gewinnbrink lesen.
Und ich habe das auch immer getan, zum Beispiel Kritik der zynischen Vernunft.
Das ist einfach ein sehr wichtiger Beitrag zur Ideologiekritik.
Ja, oder Zorn und Zeit.
Zorn und Zeit ist das Buch der Stunde, heute noch mehr als damals vor 20 Jahren oder wann als es kam.
Und wir lesen es ja heute auch deshalb, weil wir uns die ganze Zeit fragen,
was ist dann mit Europa? Wer kümmert sich eigentlich darum?
Von Ursula von der Leyen vernehmen wir eigentlich auch nur einen anschmiegsamen
Kurs an Washington, während Macron immer wieder Ideen hat, wie eigentlich Europa
zu begreifen ist, aber da hören die Deutschen dann gern weg.
Das ist aber im Falle von Sloterdijk anders.
Es war sogar so, dass er sich mit Macron getroffen hat. Macron wollte eigentlich
auch diese Vorlesungen besuchen, hat das dann zeitlich nicht geschafft.
Das heißt, wir haben es hier schon mit einem staatstragenden Philosophen zu
tun, im positiven wie negativen Sinne.
Also er ist in den Köpfen der Mächtigen durchaus zu Hause. Also sie beschäftigen sich mit seinen Thesen.
Und deswegen können wir also in Macrons Kopf vielleicht ein wenig reinschauen,
indem wir dieses Buch von Sloterdijk lesen.
Ja, ich freue mich sehr auf die Lektüre, denn Sloterdijk immer nur gewinnbringend gelesen. Immer.
Nie enttäuscht. Von daher auch ein bisschen schade, dass dann irgendwann der
Zahn der Zeit nagt und so. Ich hätte ihn ja gerne noch auch als Fernsehstar genannt.
Das war ja nicht so seine Sache, er hatte ja dieses philosophische Quartett.
Das war meine Sache als Zuschauer. Wenn es ihm kein Spaß gemacht hat, ist mir egal.
Ja, es war mitunter ein bisschen mühsam, sagen wir, in den Moderationen.
Ich habe nur beste Erinnerungen, ich fand das immer super.
Ich fand es auch jetzt im Nachhinein, wo man diese ganzen aalglatten,
geleckten Moderatoren hat, die alles wegmoderieren, was man ihnen hindickt.
Toll, dass dort jemand sich für eine Anmoderation vier Minuten Zeit nahm und
mit Formulierungen rang. Es war eigentlich gut.
Du hast recht. Ja, ja, du hast recht. Eigentlich war das noch ein Fernsehen,
das eine gewisse Plötzlichkeit zuließt. Das ist ja völlig abhandengekommen.
Heute muss man 17 Mal mit Redakteuren telefonieren und geht eigentlich schon
mal die Sendung durch und führt sie dann nochmal auf.
Ja, das Fernsehen hat heute nur noch einen Anspruch und das ist der,
den wir GPT unterstellen, Hauptsache die Grammatik stimmt und das reicht uns
nicht, weder bei der KI noch im Fernsehen.
Wir wollen, dass die Sätze auch mal krumm und schief und so.
Naja, sag uns noch, was du gelesen hast.
Bei Surkamp und wir freuen uns, wenn ihr dann mit in den Salon kommt und dass
wir darüber sprechen können.
Der Salon ist ja der Zusatzcontent zu den neuen Zwanzigern.
Das heißt, der neue Zwanziger Podcast ist frei, aber der Salon,
der dazugehört, der ist hinter der Payball und die kann man ganz einfach,
durch schreiten, indem man ein Abo abschließt. Ab drei Euro ist das möglich.
Über Patreon, wenn man schon dort ist. Wir empfehlen aber Steady.
Dort ist auch das gesamte Archiv.
Bei Patreon fehlen, glaube ich, die ersten anderthalb Jahre.
Bei Steady hat man alle Vorzüge mit Kapitelmarken und so weiter.
Ist aber, glaube ich, jetzt auch bei Patreon möglich.
Dann gibt es noch für die, die es bequem haben wollen und nicht aus ihrer Apple-Welt,
entfliehen möchten, die Möglichkeit, das über Apple zu buchen,
da ist es allerdings etwas teurer, da Apple ja noch eine extra Gebühr immer
haben möchte, damit der Konzern auch der reichste bleibt.
Ja, wir sollten es auch anders labeln, denn so wie es ist, ich habe eine kleine
Studie durch Augen auf und Hinschauen gemacht. Das Phänomen ist wie folgt.
Die Leute machen es Apple, weil sie klicken bei Apple einfach in dem Feed,
den sie schon abonniert haben, auf die bezahlbaren Inhalte, auch wenn sie in
Euro teurer sind, um sich mal warm zu hören.
Außerdem kann man bei Apple einen Monat kostenlos hören, da Apple ja eine sehr
genaue Kontrolle darüber hat, wer da bucht.
Es ist eben nicht nur eine E-Mail-Adresse, die man jeden Monat austauschen kann,
sondern eine richtige Apple-ID. und das Phänomen ist wie folgt,
dass die Leute auf Apple, also auf Apple haben wir eine ziemlich konstante Hörerzahl,
aber dann eine Abwanderung zu Steady.
Also sozusagen nicht, ihr wollt eurem Apple-Kosmos nicht entfliehen,
sondern nein, im ersten Monat kann man ruhig mal einfach nur anklicken mit einem
Klick und danach holt man sich das komplette Programm, das komplette Archiv
und so weiter bei Steady.
Finde ich eigentlich, wir haben sehr kluge Hörer, muss ich sagen, Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Ja, da haben wir also viele, viele Bücher schon besprochen und Artikel empfohlen.
Ich möchte jetzt schon mal einen Artikel empfehlen und nicht bis zum Salon damit warten.
Zunächst aber frage ich dich, wie gefällt dir der Wahlkampf?
Freust du dich auch über jeden Post, den Robert Habeck macht?
Ich habe mit Mick im Fernsehpodcast ungefähr zwei Stunden über Habeck gesprochen
und keiner kann danach behaupten, ich sei auch in irgendeiner Weise ein Habeck-Fan,
Habeck-Versteher oder sonst irgendwas.
Ich behaupte einfach mal, niemand ist in seiner Ablehnung dieser Wahlkampfästhetik
deutlicher und ausführlicher als ich und Mick.
Es ist unerträglich.
Ihr bekommt jetzt jedenfalls Unterstützung von Laura Ewert.
Die hat im Freitag einen Artikel geschrieben, der folgende Überschrift trägt.
Robert Habeck als Cringe-Minister.
Hey, na, wollen wir Freunde sein?
Und sie nimmt diesen Wahlkampf mal auseinander und auch, was da so mitschwingt,
nämlich eigentlich wird sich hier sehr angedient an Friedrich Merz schon.
Auch wenn es ein bisschen anders aussieht.
Ich bin ja auch gleich zusammengezuckt, als es hieß bei Robert Habeck Startup Deutschland.
Also wir können ja mal kurz nachdenken, was zeichnet ein Startup aus?
Flexible Arbeitszeiten, mehr als eine 40-Stunden-Woche, in der Regel noch kein
Betriebsrat, keine gewerkschaftlichen Strukturen.
Nicht mal ein Produkt, fake it till you make it. Nicht mal ein Produkt.
Unschneller Exit. Ich weiß es nicht. Er meint wahrscheinlich die Innovationskraft
und Geschwindigkeit und so etwas.
Und dass da jemand wirklich was will und Purpose hat und wie man das alles bei LinkedIn nennt.
Ich wäre aber von Arbeitnehmerseite sehr skeptisch, wenn jemand aus Deutschland
ein Startup machen möchte.
Also ich werde im Monatsende, wenn wir Podcast machen, eine ganz klare,
eindeutige Denkempfehlung hinsichtlich der nächsten Wahl geben.
Keine Wahlempfehlung, das kann
jeder selber dann ableiten, aber wir wählen Personen in dem Bundestag.
Keiner kennt seine eigenen Wahlkreisleute, aber man hat so Einblick in die Listen,
wie sie aufgestellt werden.
Nicht ohne Grund kommen ja die Parteien mit so Konzepten wie Spitzenkandidat,
Kanzlerkandidat und so weiter.
Und wenn man das so durchgeht und das auch mal abgleicht mit Büchern,
die wir am Salon besprochen haben, von Leuten, die jetzt vielleicht wählbar
sind, gibt es für mich, es ist diesmal keine Wahl, bei der ich mich frage,
ach, was soll ich bloß wählen?
Das kleinste Übel. Nein, es ist diesmal nicht so.
Ist ganz erstaunlich und da nur wenig Zeit ist bis zur Wahl,
werde ich ganz deutlich werden.
Okay, wir sind gespannt, freuen uns auf die reguläre Folge dann und alles weitere
zu Peter Sloterdijk und Europa im Salon.
Sehr gut, bis dahin.
Bis bald.